what's that belief nation welcome to
another YouTube interview I'm super
excited to be here with a new friend of
mine mr. David Bach you may recognize
the name he is a nine times New York
Times bestselling author he has over
seven million books in print and he's
considered one of the most respected
experts on all financial matters in
America he's going to chat with us for
the next half an hour David welcome
aboard man buddy it's good to be with
you and I like I said hey we're wearing
matching hoodies here so like we're
instantly soul connected is the hoodie
tribe this is a real this is well this
is what I'm wearing on a normal day when
I'm not going to a television studio I
like this is the real me - I like it
authenticity is super-important on
YouTube I mean a lot of people know your
name they read your blog's have been to
your events for the for the people who
aren't familiar with you yet and this is
their first introduction what is what is
the mission like what do you try to
accomplish you've been doing this for a
long time for the huge impact what do
you what are you trying to do out there
yeah well you know I've spent 25 years
really being a teacher when it comes of
the concept of money um I've been
teaching classes on personal finance
since 1993 and Mike one of the first
classes I ever taught was the class on
women and money and the story behind
that is I learned about money from my
grandma Rose Bach my first book smart
women finished rich was dedicated to her
she was broke at 30 living paycheck to
paycheck and she turned from whole her
whole life around by learning around
learning about money and investing and
became a millionaire and then really
taught my family how to do this so when
I came into the investment business that
are really a relatively young age in my
20s I saw a lot of women unlike my
grandmother who are being hurt
financially by divorce and by widowhood
and by a lack of knowledge around money
and so at a really young age of my
twenties I just became very passionate
about teaching classes on women and
money and that's what really started my
career I taught a course in Lafayette
California for women and money and I
think it's gonna be doing the same thing
now since 1993 I've just had a chance to
do it on bigger and bigger stages and
venues but you know I I'm doing in
essence the same thing for 25 years
because I still just love it I love when
people have that what I call the aha
moment where you're speaking on stage
right now like right now it's over video
but where you realize that the person
gets it and they're gonna change your
life because you said something that
really flipped the switch I love being
an activator everything I've tried to do
in my whole life is about action I
always say fight you know financial
education without you taking action is
just entertainment so like like being
here with you right now in the next 30
minutes I hope to inspire educate but
activate people to take action because I
know I'm gonna share things next 28
minutes that literally if people go and
follow my plan it'll change your whole
life financially I love it and I love to
see the energy and excitement still
happening like 25 years in and what
you're doing it you know really shows
that you super care but what you're
trying to do now you have an interesting
concept called the latte factor and
you're writing a new book and in the pre
like we were in the green room you
showed me like a sneak peek of this new
book coming out sometime next year tell
us what it's blue sit here nobody else
knows about this now except for you and
everybody we're telling on on YouTube my
age it hasn't even seen this yet I love
it I love the sneak peek for people who
don't know what the latte factor is give
us a quick summary what is the latte
factor alright so the story behind the
latte factor goes back to me teaching
one of my first classes and I used to
teach a four-week class on money and at
the end of my four week classes I'm
wrapping up the class getting ready for
the big clothes you know how that is I
had a young woman named Kim raise your
hand and say oh sorry about that that's
my phone back there but that's real life
right I had a young woman thing to me
you know David I can't view this I can't
I can't pay myself first I can't save
money automatically these were all great
ideas in theory but I can't do that
and so I was in a classroom literally
with a chalkboard and what I did was go
Kim look we've got 10 minutes left in
the class let me prove to you that you
can save five dollars a day
will you play the game with me and and
then I asked the class like is it okay
if if we do this for Kim and everybody
was like yeah yeah do it so I walked up
to a chalkboard and I started going
through Kim's expenses and remember Kim
had told me she couldn't save any money
she couldn't use her 401k plan she
worked at the gap she couldn't pay
herself first and as we're going through
expenses she's sipping a latte and so
I'm going through her expenses and I'm
it wasn't just lot days it was a bunch
of other stuff it was all the places
she'd eat now and I'm writing all the
stuff down the chalkboard and I started
doing some basic math and I go look Kim
you just need to save $10 a day you're
in your 20s if you'll save $10 a day you
can be a millionaire by the time you
reach retirement and I calculated the
number out for her and it came out to
like 1.7 million dollars and she she
sort of looked at me and she goes are
you trying to tell me my latte here is
costing me over a million dollars and a
woman in the front seat who is kind of
aggravated turned around and went that's
exactly what he's trying to tell you you
have a latte factor and you know the
class wrapped up and everybody was
talking about it and as I'm walking out
of the room I'm like I think I should
keep teaching this idea and and so the
latte factor was born and the latte
factor is a metaphor I'm not trying to
take people's coffee away it is a
metaphor for look five to ten dollars it
could change your life if you don't
believe you can save you'll never save a
dollar days of good start right so if
you don't believe you can save if you
don't believe you have the money to be
an investor you'll never invest and the
logic factors of metaphor to inspire
people to realize you have more money
than you think
you're richer than you think and once
you realize that you'll start to take
action and that can change your whole
life not it and and for people already
interested what is this book gonna come
out day but they want their they want
their advance copies what happening well
a lot of girls gonna we're gonna go sell
in the next 90 days
here's my dream with a latte factor I've
been wanting to write this book for 10
years literally it's been a 10-year
project and I'm co-writing it with a
gentleman named John Mann who wrote this
great book called the go-giver and we're
writing it as a parable because I want
the book to translate all over the world
my goal it's a little story and it will
hopefully translate all over the world
so we can kind of create like the who
moved my cheese of personal finance
before them you can go out and get the
automatic millionaire because that's
what started it all this book has done
like almost 2 million copies now
worldwide and can I know you're in
Canada it's also translated for
candidates for Canadians go read the
automatic owner we just put it out as a
brand new edition that book is available
right now in stores you can go to our
website give it back calm and here's the
other book smart couples finish rich
that's also been updated this year just
came out in January sale we got two
books for you you can see my little
stickies in here because I've been
working on the other book right now like
well guys we have David for the next a
little bit I want to get to some
questions that you guys are having if
you tagged me in the livestream it's
easy for me to see where questions are
David already some of the people are
writing in about how do i balance my
finances as an entrepreneur people are
worried they don't have enough money put
into their business how do I also now
save on top of it capitals one issue
that comes up over and over and over
again from people who are starting the
business is it just a question a belief
or what do you recommend like how do we
take latte factor or automatic
millionaire and apply to an entrepreneur
setting so I love that I love speaking
entrepreneurs I've basically been one my
entire life
right 25 years of being an entrepreneur
and I've been an organization called
used to be called Yeo now it's called yo
entrepreneurs organizations all over the
world and I love when I go speak to you
that's because I kind of get in a lot of
my entrepreneur buddies faces and and so
I'm gonna not try to get too much in
your face but here's what I tell my
entrepreneur buddies right like the
biggest myth for most entrepreneurs is
that they will work on their business
and that they will someday sell it and
that will be the retirement money and so
you know when you're building a business
I see so many entrepreneurs reinvesting
all of their money in their business to
grow grow grow grow grow and the hopeful
expectation at some point they'll have
an exit and then the exit will be where
their their retirement and their funny
security will come firm and for most
entrepreneurs the truth is that is a
fantasy
it just is I hate to tell you but it's a
fantasy most businesses rarely have
exits and they certainly rarely have
exits for over a million dollars and we
live in a world today where we're always
reading about the billion dollar exit I
have and I mean I'm an investor in
companies that are having 100
million-dollar exits but they're the
exception not the rule
so what I tell entrepreneurs is you have
to also think candidly like you would if
you were an employee and what that means
is like if you're an employee you know
you're not gonna have an exit you know
that if I don't use my fall on K plan I
mean who knows if Social Security's
gonna be you know around in 50 years if
I don't use if I don't save money in a
retirement account I'm never gonna have
any money the problem for entrepreneurs
is they don't think like that
and so like 75% of entrepreneurs today
most who are watching this show actually
don't have a retirement account and they
don't have a SEP IRA account or where
you are you know it's an RSP or a 401 k
plan I see entrepreneurs who who set up
401 k plans for their employees and they
don't use them so you have to be putting
yourself first by paying yourself first
you have to now if you're a smart
entrepreneur and you have a lot of smart
entrepreneurs watching this show who
don't have employees there are very
specific things you can do you can open
up a solo 401 k plan for an example in
the u.s. super simple plan where you can
automatically be saving money you can
put up to fifty five thousand dollars a
year away in that plan tax deductible
you can open it to find benefit plan
like in the automatic Miller this year
you can shield two hundred and twenty
thousand dollars tax deductable into a
defined benefit plan that's money that
you literally I take it put it away
don't pay taxes with the government so
entrepreneurs often are not taking
advantage of those plans and they should
the other thing I teach entrepreneurs is
you got to buy the real estate that your
business is in like my experience I
started my career Morgan Stanley my
wealthiest clients became wealthy in
many cases by accident because they
bought the building that their business
and you know if you're gonna be in an
office space for twit for ten years you
could own the office potentially if you
go out and make that a goal and in 10 15
20 years they you own that real estate
free and clear if you sell the business
someday that the person who buys the
business can rent back from you it's a
great way to build wealth should an
entrepreneur ever cash out their
retirement savings to grow or launch
their business no no no I mean literally
I can't I can't over
I can't over say that like no no you
shouldn't and and and and so many
entrepreneurs do it is a last resort
place to get money now I know it happens
like in the recession I saw a lot of my
friends have to tap their retirement
accounts and in many cases they're just
kind of getting back to you know where
they were before because they've now had
a good you know way I've had nine years
to rebuild it but know if you start
there's two things you really shouldn't
do as an entrepreneur tap your 401k plan
or your IRA account for multiple reasons
number one if you're not borrowing it
out of your 401k plan you're cashing it
out which means you're losing half of it
to taxes and penalties it's the most
expensive money you can basically get
like have have ten thousand dollars pull
it out of your retirement account now
you're down to five so that's that's not
a good and plus you've lost all the
compound interest so that's not a good
thing to do the only good not a good
thing to do is lines of credit the bank
is happy to give you lines of credit
when the market is good like now you
know now that we're at an all-time high
in the stock market and the real estate
market the economy every day if I go
when I go downstairs and I grab my mail
there's an offer from somebody with an
instant line of a hundred thousand
dollar line of credit
I must get five emails you know not a
day but certainly a week of bankers
reaching out to me to loan me money
including goldman sachs is emailed me
three times in the last seven days so
once once you the economy is doing well
everybody will loan you money what
entrepreneurs do though which is a
disaster is when they start to live off
that line of credit even though they're
like using it then paying it down using
it to paying it down when the economy
turns and a does term that's where
entrepreneurs get wipe
and I saw a lot of my EO buddies go
through a lot of pain in 2008 2009 and
2010 I saw a lot of big businesses turn
upside down where you know things went
like this and then by the way what is
the bank - as soon as as soon as the
economy slows down and what is the bank
to you with that line of credit they
call it and then you don't have the
money to pay it so you know probably
some people right now just went like
their stomach just went like like that
but I'm telling you right now with the
economy in a very very strong place so
we are out right now you need to be very
careful about taking this money that
seems free from the bank
sorry bankers I don't know how many
bankers we have in here but the ones who
do want to start their own company
Darren is right in this case the
question I have for David around the
latte factor are you saving five dollars
every day or every time you get well
five dollars it's got to be at least
five dollars a day right like every time
you only got saved five dollars and time
you got paid you'd be saving ten bucks a
month which means you would be saving
$120 a year so no that's not enough you
know simple basic math if you're making
fifty grand a year another way to think
about this is if you save one hour day
of your income that's what I teach
people who have jobs right like one hour
day of your income if you make $50,000 a
year one hour day of your income means
you will save over five thousand dollars
a year one hour day of your income if
you're gonna work an eight nine ten hour
day you should be keeping an hour day of
your income and and that's kind of like
we were talking about the aha moment
right like you know I always say you're
gonna work ninety thousand hours over
your lifetime you should keep one hour
day of your income now we know actually
mathematically for a fact when you look
at self-made millionaires in 401k plans
the largest company that does this is
fidelity they have over a hundred
thousand millionaires in their fallen K
plans and what they saved was 14% of
their gross income which is a little
over an hour day of your income the
average American today is saving less
than 15 minutes a day of their income so
what
if you go back to the $10 a day $10 a
days 300 bucks a month
that's over 3600 ollars a year you save
that for decades and by the time you got
a lot of people watching this in their
20s by the time you turn around your 60s
you could have over a million dollars in
savings
now the pushback is people say oh but a
million dollars in you know 40 years
isn't gonna be worth anything so gonna
be worth a whole lot more than zero
right like yeah yeah it's the right now
one out of two Americans hat can't get
their hands on $400 in case of emergency
purposes that's the Federal Reserve
statistic last year forty six and a half
percent of Americans reportedly cannot
get their hands on $400 in case of
emergency purposes now five million
people will go to Starbucks probably
today and have five dollar lattes so
again I'm not telling you you can't have
your latte but I'm trying to show you
that you know we spend lots of money on
little things I'm drinking water right
now as we talk and it's free but the lot
the water industry when I started doing
this was a billion dollars a year the
bottled water industry now is fifteen
billion dollars a year the bulk of which
is tap water put in plastic bottles with
great branding so you know water
cigarettes you name it like think
through where are you spending the money
and then redirected savings I like it
and take a sip of water that's the voice
I like it so some people are questioning
the math and and saying it's like ends
up being five figures in 50 years
because they're not taking the into
account obviously you're invest in it
right so you put the money in your
invest in it what it's called pound
interest right so like here I'll just
like literally like look at the chart
here I'm gonna run it this is a chart in
Latin I'll give you very specific
numbers that are in the automatic
millionaire ten dollars a day in one
year it's three thousand seven and
seventy dollars if you get a 10% rate of
returns let me quote to return for a
second then I'll explain that return 10
percent is three thousand seven and
seven T dollars you go up to ten years
it's sixty one thousand dollars you go
out to 30 years it's six hundred and
seventy eight thousand dollars you go
out to forty years it's 1 million eight
hundred ninety seven thousand two
twenty-four dollars now that's a
hypothetical number right like you're
not getting a guaranteed ten percent
rate of return anywhere the stock market
however since 1926 if you've just been
in the market with reinvested dividends
has annualized out at ten percent a year
now people know that you can't make ten
percent since 2009 since the bottom of
the market the market area actually
averaged 17 percent annually do I think
it's a no-brainer to make 10 percent
know you got a plea I've got in the
books to plug different numbers that you
don't believe ten percent plug in five
percent but you have to plug it in you
have to run a you can go Google anywhere
compound interest calculators and run
the number and you can plug in your own
numbers the rate of return is not what
people should get caught up on what
people should get caught up on is the
amount of money they say I wouldn't plug
in the rate of return over ten percent I
can tell you that what is the what do
pension plans - though all the largest
pension plans in the world their
annualized rate of return on average
their expectations that they've plugged
in for all these government employees
and all these corporations is about
eight percent so and that's a blended
portfolio stocks and bonds and cash so
you want to be conservative plugging it
for some but you got to get the money
saving in order to create the miracle of
compound interest I like it
and and automatic millionaire has a lot
of those the data the stats like for
anybody who wants to know the math just
go pick up the book you'll you'll learn
him yeah I can give me a couple apps to
that people can use you only give you a
couple resources sure you have your own
or other resources well so what I'll
give you an app that's called one of
them's called clarity money it's it's to
me the best app that you can use right
now to track where all your money's
going because you sort of have to first
see where your money's going to believe
you can save the money so clarity money
calm is a apps been out for about two
years one of those popular apps in
America I don't know it's not everywhere
worldwide but you can quickly track
where everything's going what I love
about this app is that not only can you
track where you mines going on a daily
basis but you can actually save right
inside the app I'm an investor an
advisor clarity money also in an
investor in another company called
acorns acorns is like basically taking
the latte factor concept and made saving
money automatically with as little as a
dollar a day super easy and inside of
the clarity money app once you track
where your money is going you can
basically click a but a button and start
to have money saved automatically into a
quorum so the to soar worked nice and
seamlessly together great your people
are asking for the names again so
clarity money and acorn yep acorns ACO
RN s calm over by the way from
Millennials it's it's the
fastest-growing financial service
company in the world for Millennials we
vote there's over three million accounts
now I believe it's just unbelievable and
it's because what acorns did was take
the latte factor and make it available
to invest for everyone because the other
thing I would get pushed back on was
well how do we invest a dollar a day or
how do we invest five dollars a day and
acorns does that and again in clarity
money you can do it right inside the app
like it Zachary is writing in to say
David what is your biggest piece of
advice for a young college student in
terms of managing our finances young
college student boy it's so it's so much
easier when you start when you're young
so like I have these charts in the book
where I show now if you start when
you're 19 and you save two thousand
dollars a year and you save it from 19
to the age of 26 and you never save
another dollar and you just let it
compound and grow and then I show
somebody who starts at 26 and says from
26 to 65 the 19 year old that's saved
from 19 to 26 ends up with more money
than the 26 year olds you save to 65 so
so the biggest advice I can give you on
your young is to start young even if all
you do is go open up a Roth IRA and
again just start putting five dollars a
day away so the miracle of compound
interest when you're young makes
everything so much easier
the second thing I will tell you is just
be super careful about debt so you know
I learned the hard way I was in college
I was dumb and I got in credit card debt
in college and you can ruin your life by
actually very quickly with credit card
debt if you get a credit card and you
don't pay it on time or you don't pay it
which a lot of college students is what
happens you can destroy your credit
score like like that like in 90 days you
can ruin your credit score and one
thing's about ruining your credit score
when you're young is it impacts okay it
can impact your life for decades it can
it can impact your ability to get a job
because employers pull credit scores
today it could impact your ability to
get a home loan or a car loan or a
business loan so you know one of the
things that my dad did for me when I was
in college when I came home with that
first credit card bill and I said dad we
have a problem he handed the credit card
bill back to me and he said hey how many
said son we don't have a problem you
have a problem and he said I mean it was
probably the greatest gift ever
if you ruin your credit score you will
ruin your financial edge so don't do it
and so you know that was a big
eye-opener for me at the age of 19
that's what led me to entrepreneurship I
figured out I couldn't make enough money
with a job to pay off that credit card
by the time I got out of college and
that's what led me to be an entrepreneur
in college was out of necessity I had to
go make more money that could make it a
$10 an hour job do you see part of what
you're doing is passing on your father's
legacy in terms of the advice and the
wisdom he gave you now you're sharing it
with others totally and my grandmother I
mean my group you know I've ace I the
amazing thing is the ripple effect of
life my grandmother helped me buy my
first stock at age seven and then and
then my dad was a financial advisor and
I started going to his investment
classes at 9:00 and evening but my dad's
still alive and you know it's cool they
get to see me now to do this stuff but
like I'm completely passing on the
legacy and I don't know if my kids will
pass it on but I'm teaching my kids now
how to invest like I did like I bought
my first talking McDonald's I live
across the street from Shake Shack here
in New York so now my kids own Shake
Shack right so it's it's teaching these
less
that were taught to me now to my kids
I've got an 8 year old and a 14 year old
and I keep you know hammering I was
trying to explain to my eight my 14
early che why his hundred and seventy
dollar hoody which he told me was was a
good deal was not a good deal I'm like
what well you got a hundred and seven
dollar D it took me fifty-one years to
get to have a hoodie that cost over a
hundred bucks
who bought you this hoodie where did the
maze-like my son's doing with a lot of
these kids do which is their buying
stuff and selling it online so he's
already kind of get to be an
entrepreneur I like it well your your
America's financial father that people
don't have themselves I like it
a whole bunch of people are asking
questions around where they should be
investing percentages into real estate
stocks mutual funds do you have wisdom
on where people should be putting their
money well so it's always hard to
simplify this and answer this question
right because it totally appends on your
age and your goals and your risk
tolerance the one things I've done to
very I guess
simplified is to say look if you have
your money don't call your money never
in one basket right it's like you know
please don't put all your money right
now in Bitcoin I see so many young
people that are just betting the farm on
cryptocurrency so many people are gonna
get just really hurt there you know it
reminds me of the dot-com days when I
was a kid oh yeah I think you weren't
even born yet but like the dot-com days
you know everybody was gonna get rich
overnight and dot-com stocks and then
everybody became poor overnight so don't
ever bet the farm on any one thing I
recommend your assets get divided
roughly a third real estate a third
guaranteed investments and a third
diversified in the in the stock market
that very generic approach is one that
never hurts you and happens to be it
also gives you a very solid rate of
return but for our clients you know I
own a registered investment advisory
firm we have advisors all over the
country and for our most of our clients
are retired we just build very deeply
diversified portfolios are typical
portfolio for our retired clients has 19
asset classes its diversified among over
40 countries using lots of different
money managers and you know over 12,000
securities individual stocks and bonds
so
diversification is your friend it's not
an it's not an approach to getting rich
overnight but it's a phenomenal approach
to not going poor overnight and that's
like that's a very important thing to
like remember guys because some of you
will make a lot of money at a young age
if you get lucky you make a lot of money
young age is the thing that really sucks
is losing it all and you know you read
all these great things and stories on
YouTube and you watch these videos of
people who you know they went bankrupt
and they came back and went bankrupt
they came back if you can fortune up to
make a lot of money at a young age don't
go bankrupt don't come back just just
get to the top of the mountain then make
sure you you stay there okay I'm just
thinking for people how much is
self-education important I'm wondering
for people want to invest our money
should they learn how to do it
themselves should they hire a
professional you know the value of
accountants in business for forgiving
you you know tax loopholes and ways to
avoid like how much is how important is
it for us to learn ourselves how to do
it versus hire and profession to help us
out it's critical right look the reason
people are watching your show is because
they're they're you're pursuing further
knowledge right that's why they're here
you can't just hire a financial advisor
or a tax accountant and know nothing to
delegate it I mean you can and people do
it but the reason but it's but much
better to be educated first like I
literally wrote these books smart
couples finish rich someone reads this
book and then they go meet with a
financial advisor they know every single
question asked because it's important if
you ever do delegate your financial your
money to someone else you want to make
sure that whoever you've delegated it to
is honest ethical and not taking
advantage of you you need to know the
questions to ask and then you need to
know what to watch out for because again
why do you so many people lose a lot of
money when they invest because they
don't know what they don't know but you
can go pick up books or watch videos
like this and learn a lot and you know
what one thing I'll just say cuz I don't
we don't have a whole lot more time left
is when someone tells you they're gonna
get you rich overnight you should run
alright like the video but the banner
that popped up that said you know we can
make you rich overnight like no they
can't and the other thing I'll tell you
the opposite of that is true sometimes
people come you as something that is not
a get-rich-quick scheme could say we can
help you get a higher rate of return on
your money but super safe you don't need
to worry those can also be very day
games because those are often people
they're a complete scam artists and I
talk about the different ways in which
people try to rip you off and some are
couples finish rich because they're so
they're very specific warning signs of
what to watch out for and the thing
that's unfortunate is you come across
one bad person in a lifetime and if you
don't protect your wallet and you let
that person take your money it can ruin
your life
so education it's you can't get enough
and you should never stop eleven David
thank you for your time for people who
want to learn more about you they're
waiting for the last a factor to come
out next year
where are you act where can they follow
you where can they learn more yeah Evan
thank for well thanks for having me on
your show it's been awesome come visit
me at David Volcom David ball calm or
finish rich calm they take you same
place you want to go straight to the
website on smart couples go to smart
couples finish rich calm you can
download a couple chapters the book for
free right there and we've got a
newsletter we send out called three
minutes Sunday which I send out on
Sundays when I have time to read it
amazing David thank you so much your
time thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon awesome have a great day